[Music]
first of all I want to start by
congratulating you you you married I did
I wet lovely you Wed the lovely Austin
bells beautiful girl best girl out next
our wives she's our three and your eyes
had a baby girl we sure did yeah yeah
it's wonderful
yeah human life it's so fun now this
opens up a lot of questions first of all
you know before you have a kid it's all
theoretical then the baby shows up are
you thinking it's real would you say
things get real yeah so you think you're
gonna be a protective dad or kind of a
easygoing dad you don't evaluate my
mother I had a fantastic why I still
have a fantastic mother and she was
ultra ultra honest with us and that's
gonna be my policy ultra honest yellow
sugarcoat things no no this is a real
thing that happened in about second
grade on the playground I overheard one
kid call another kid a buck humper but
hunter yes and I was familiar with both
what a buck was and what humping was so
I what was confused by those two things
together right so that night at dinner
at the dinner table I asked my mom I
said you know I heard these kids on the
playground once it was called my butt
humper is this something people do they
but humph and my mother without skipping
a beat wasn't nervous she goes there's a
lot of nerve endings in the anus in son
some women what some women find it
pleasurable and many don't and she was
right
exactly
what serration found their dad it's low
yeah they're not uniformly distributed
nerve endings I guess Oh suddenly
suddenly you're a biological nervin know
what a heartbeat is expert on parts per
million nerve endings and anus she said
that and you know I don't understand I'm
not in that school and you know what you
don't I know I wrote what would you say
did I hear what you would say
but humping I would say that's a magical
elfin he lives in the trees
I would then when they get asked abut
hump they'll go yes you know I went I
don't think I have nerve valves in my
anus okay I don't want to know the act
it would be ill-prepared I don't want it
going on a lollipop journey through an
enchanted for my point is I diverged
from my wife my wife is tells them the
absolute truth about everything no yeah
I grew up in a family where they didn't
tell us anything we were fed
misinformation and look how I turned out
that's the comedy we're both sitting in
the exact same spot yeah virtually no
what I'm saying is I'm not sure I think
sometimes you can give kids too much
information do you think we're gonna
find out my household what are you gonna
do what are you gonna do what are you
gonna say to your kids everything and
anything that's the truth
barring maybe some kind of morbid things
like death or nuclear holocaust right
you're not gonna mention death to them
no I'll say gonna pause on vacation what
do you Annie where are you on this whole
spectrum do you tell your kids
everything yeah yeah we're pretty
honestly I can figure you worried my my
daughter just recently told my wife that
she was ready to have the sex talk she
said and which is how she said she said
mom I'm ready to have the sex talk she's
eight yeah and do you need my mother's
phone number no no my wife had the sex
talk with her and my my daughter
apparently listened and then went that
is the most interesting thing I have
ever heard
he'll probably be a scientist yeah yeah
I was told that stuff when I was 36
years old
I still don't believe it